[Music]
all right the medium mob and it is a mob
they're now completely unhinged they're
only getting worse goes for Hollywood -
look at this Universal Pictures set to
release a brand new movie about hunting
yes irredeemable deplorable for sport
you know we smelly Trump Walmart voters
that cling to our God guns religion and
Bibles
well now the movies been pulled
meanwhile just last week you had the
psychos a conspiracy TV MSDN see this
time the kool Wallace claiming that the
president called for the extermination
of Latinos okay don't expect a real
apology from anybody over there this is
pretty much every second minute hour of
their day as they follow conspiracy
theorists the best of them all
Roswell Rachel Maddow won't be apologies
they'll just make up the next conspiracy
joining us now with reaction the hills
Joe Concha you know look I don't expect
any I don't expect them to ever admit
they're wrong I don't expect them to own
it I don't expect them to change they
are who they are and I think now they've
kind of been exposed and the president's
done a good job of tattooing fake news
into their branding and I don't think
they ever get beyond it I'm sure so I
mean why would they apologize if there's
never any accountability why would Mika
Brzezinski ever apologize for saying
that the president's actually rooting
for mass shootings shootings to happen
in this country why would Joe
Scarborough ever apologize for throwing
out a conspiracy theory that the
Russians somehow had a hand in the
killing of Jeffrey Epstein
why would MSNBC ever apologize for
putting on a former FBI assistant
director who said that he the president
was only re raising flags on eight eight
because that's a bat signal to neo-nazis
so if there's never any accountability
of course nothing's going to happen and
look as for the hunt try to picture a
world Sean where supporters of Elizabeth
Warren or Alexandra Castillo Cortes are
hunted and gunned down by pro Trump
supporters and then try to picture the
media reaction the the the pitchforks
and torches store would run out of
pitchforks and torches and be on
backorder for months and the media
reaction would be apocalyptic in terms
of front page wall the wall 24/7
linking that back to the next mass
shooting and saying this is what incited
that violence so yeah look I think the
president deserves credit he said quote
the movie coming out the hunt is made in
order to inflame and cause chaos they
create their own violence and then try
to blame others that is precisely right
and that's why that movie was pulled a
day or two later the backlash was just
too overwhelming Sean for all the
criticism of Donald Trump at the root of
it though there's a deeper anger that's
there really is a belief system that
we're smelling Walmart voters we are
irredeemable deplorable that week I'm
guilty I try to cling to God be a better
person yeah I believe in the Second
Amendment Bible yeah I believe in the
Bible and religion I think is good for
society I happen to be a Christian
judeo-christian principles built this
country I don't know I think insulting
the American people and their choice
isn't gonna work well for them your
thoughts it will it will not because you
think of the turning point in 2016 Sean
when Hillary Clinton called Trump
supporters a basket of deplorable that
changed the whole game and that's what
gave the president his momentum
ultimately and winning that election all
right Joe thank you